hi I'm John Warner game director for
Anthem
[Music]
[Music]
freelancer Braxley
listen big trouble big trouble what did
you do mistake I hired some people they
weren't freelancers I know they said
they could handle it and the price was
right I thought maybe unbelievable
you're right
it was stupid I'm sorry but they're
still out there somewhere if you could
just bring them back anything you need
I'll get to it tomorrow all right in the
world of anthem you and your friends are
freelancers the heroes who leave the
safety of the walls of for Tarsus to
explore the unknown tech community looks
join two players as they head out of an
expedition
hey Paul you ready to go prescribe some
supplies already what are you going to
use today I decided to go with the
Colossus huh
I'm going to use my ranger try out some
new upgrades
[Music]
every player will run an array of EXO
students we call Javanese these suit to
give players superhuman capabilities and
are heavily customizable so they look
and play or you are damn looking good
nice you better mortar equipped yeah I
got on the weekend you lead the way
this is a vast open world to explore
with your friend
each javelin exosuit is only weeks later
the Ranger is balanced Melford
well the philosophy of tanking power Oh
spirits up here the world of anthem is
hostile and threats can come from any
direction because I nematodes of the
unexpected is about every corner I'm not
sure one solar supplies on this guy yeah
he seems like a problem for another day
weirdest part the heavy although low you
flank
hang in there up there
have you been in there yet
I haven't I wish to do that later with
Kim you could use the XP
hello expression
I think we got some action back
anyone anyone we're under attack anyone
in the area we're under attack
that's quite a praxis mission
you can equip your javelin exosuits this
gear that brings devastating power to
commerce oh there are a lot of scars
down there all the scars have a heavy
time use that mortar covering fire
there's a bunch more coming in okay I'll
get there
oh come on
feeling good uh yes Jerez wrath oh nice
large-scale world events like shapers
are dynamic and pulled you off the
beaten path with the promise of new
stories to discover
Oh super storm incoming okay
actually let's get some more people hold
on a second hey guys what's up hey
what's happening
right behind you
Oh
the storm is getting crazy
what are we supposed to do fly into it
all right let's do this
you're on your side
our story is out there
[Music]
you